hi everyone so welcome back to another
video working through some of the math
behind quantum mechanics and this is
going to be the last video in this
series working up to the Fineman path
integral and looking at some more of the
math or the direct notation the bracket
notation of how to get there for a very
quick summary of what I covered last
time I'm on this page here and we learnt
that a measurement can disturb the
system and collapse the state so that is
one of those fundamental things about
quantum mechanics that actually making a
measurement will change what you're
working with it collapses the state of
the quantum particle once an input state
like this has been observed to say spin
up the output state is no longer the
wave function but has been collapsed
into spin up and we spoke last time
about these projections so this here is
an outer product where you have a kit
and then a bra next to each other once a
neutron emerges from the up channel that
means it was measured to be spin up it's
no longer in this input state anymore
it's now in the state represented by the
up projection with the input state this
is now its collapse state here you can
use that to rewrite our probabilities of
observing an up Neutron so if our input
state is sy our collapsed output state
of being measured up is this then our
probabilities are these inner products
here so this is where we did leave off
last time we were talking about this
experiment where we were recombining two
channels and then in our combined
channel we were getting a
hundred-percent spin up which made us
think that there was some memory that
the quantum particles had where they
could remember all the way back to what
they were here and for some reason that
hadn't been reset by this experiment in
the middle which usually is what would
happen so we've discovered that our
mathematical way of representing you
know the probability of this added to
the probability of this was not giving
us this probability here so
there was something wrong with our
mathematical approach with the classical
probability the fact was that the
combined channels here could not be
treated as just a mix of different
neutrons but we needed to devise some
mathematical framework to represent that
these neutrons here that have been
combined are a superposition of spin
left and spin right so let's see how
we're going to do that so going back to
our outer products we use them to
represent the act of measurement by
applying this projection to our
appropriate state
so these projection operators are going
to be what we're going to use to
represent essentially which channel the
neutrons have passed through okay we can
mathematically represent combining these
two states here by summing the
measurement outer products together and
acting on the ket state the state
prepared by properly combining the beams
from the second analyzer is a coherent
superposition of the eigenvectors of the
second analyzer so that's another way to
say it but it is this superposition that
we're trying to represent mathematically
so using the sum of the x aligned
projection operators that's just these
here what is the merge state after the
SG X analyzer so that's the second one
so which one of these options sums these
two projection operators well it looks
to me like this one here is out on our
bottom this one here is the projection
operator from the top and that's all
acting on our input ket state so this
looks like the right answer to me and
87% of people agreed yes so then they
just go through expanding the brackets
here there and you can see what you get
one important thing to remember is that
if you sum all the possible outer
products which we have done here because
there were only two possibilities
it creates an identity matrix
essentially it's like the number one
when you times one by anything the state
changed so we're able to sum over all
these outer products without actually
changing the input state so now that we
have our coherent superposition state
emerging from the second analyzer to
calculate the probability of each
measurement and the third analyzer
requires taking the inner product with
the possible output States and squaring
their magnitude so that's how we've been
finding the probabilities is doing this
inner product between me
I guess collapsed state and what you're
using and squaring the magnitude of that
this remember that the inner product is
like the overlap between two things so
if there's a lot of overlap between two
different things there's a high
probability of that occurring I think
that's sort of the way that I think of
it okay so in this case this is our
superposition here and that's what we
learned to represent it's the sum of
these outer products with our
essentially our input state so that's
what it started as it was spin up and
now we've got this superposition here
with that to get the probability we'll
take the inner product of this
superposition with either spin up or
spin down so a Christian here just to
make sure we're on the right track what
path does this amplitude correspond to
in the analyzer below okay so let's have
a look at it we've got a spin left
projection in the middle here so it must
be yellow path see started spin up a
projection to the left and then an inner
product with spin up so I would say that
as path C and 83% of people agree with
me so you can have a little look at all
of these if you still need a bit more
clarification to you know match these
paths which with the path that they're
taking through the system but
essentially the all of this path is just
represented in these four arrows here in
our bracket notation that's why
was quite handy to be able to write
things down like this all right so when
we go to calculate those probabilities
which we expressed on the previous page
so if you take that Plus that the
magnitude squared you get four terms you
get two squared terms plus interference
or cross terms now they're going to work
through it here but there's one thing to
refresh your mind on or learn here and
that was on a previous page and that's
when you just for example are taking
probabilities the squared absolute value
is also written as the product of an
inner product and it's complex conjugate
so the complex conjugate of a inner
product means you can either swap the
order of the letters so you can swap the
bra and the kit or you can put this
little star on it which represents that
it's the complex ecology it in more
common terms a complex conjugate means
the sign of a complex value is flipped
so if say we had a complex number that
was like 2 plus I the complex conjugate
of that would be 2 minus I so there's
brilliant goes through a bit more of
this complex conjugates TAF and how
complex numbers are relate to this
quantum mechanics in one of the previous
courses it's called unavoidable
complexity but just for what we're going
to do know that the squared absolute
magnitude here can be rewritten as an
inner product times its complex
conjugate so when we go to expand this
probability we have our two squared
terms and then our two cross terms are
written out using that fact and writing
the complex conjugate times an inner
product as a way instead of writing V
squared absolute magnitude it says here
that our cross terms which I guess are
these two could be positive or negative
we don't really know so this is our
probability for the spin up I think it
says that for the probability of being
spin down the interference terms which
work out to be negative
of causing the total probability to be
zero which seems quite interesting and
leads into I guess what is our final
point and I guess what it says we've
stumbled onto a way to sum the
amplitudes over all possible paths and
we've seen it has a deep connection to
the behavior of quantum objects so
really we know that from our experiment
we were getting a hundred percent of the
neutrons emerging from the up channel
and none from the down Channel but now
we have you know a positive probability
for emerging from the up channel and
zero probability of emerging from the
down channel just coming out in the
mathematics by summing over all the
possible options and that really gets
into the heart of what is called the
Fineman path integral or summing over
all histories now the Fineman path
integral is often represented in many
different ways you might have seen it or
you might come to see it represented as
an exponential or relating to an
integral of the action of a system but
this is a way that we can see a glimpse
of how it's working we discovered that
summing all the possible paths a neutron
could have taken to the third analyzer
resulted in interference when we say the
amplitudes interfere with one another it
means that they are reinforcing or
cancelling each other out at various
points for different measurements in
quantum mechanics this approach is not
limited to neutron star traveling
through magnetic fields but is a core
part of quantum field theories for all
particles so that idea of constructive
or destructive interference you probably
would have seen in waves so we were like
if the top of two waves are at the same
point you get a an extra-big wave but if
you have the top of a wave meaning the
bottom of the wave they cancel out
nothing and you'll get flat water so
that is essentially what's happening
here with these particles with our waves
of probability in a way when adding up
all the possible paths for a neutron to
take the probability of it taking a
detour to the edge of the
and coming back will cancel out with the
idea of it taking a detour and the other
direction edge of the universe and
coming back all the paths that I guess
stray from what you see classically end
up canceling each other out and that
gives us our classical result that it is
the highest probability because it is
the one where there isn't destructive
interference so what we see in the world
around us essentially emerges from
quantum mechanics by the fact that even
small deviations away from the path that
we see classically will have very small
probability amplitudes or will
destructively cancel each other out and
constructively give us what we do see is
our classical path to have the highest
probability amplitude by by far and this
I think is a really cool aspect of
physics and of quantum mechanics because
path integrals like I said actually can
also be expressed by calculating the
action of a system which is something I
haven't spoken about but comes into
calculating I guess the path of least
resistance or the path of least action
through a system and this is just where
I wanted to get you guys to through this
math for quantum mechanics series as
seeing this emergence of the path
integral because there is multiple
different ways that I think you could
derive it or come to understand it so
I'm going to leave this series here but
there is so much more on brilliant and
on textbooks and online to continue your
a quantum physics journey but I hope
this was a little bit of a boost to get
you in the right direction in terms of
some of the mathematics as always if you
do want to work through this material
celfon brilliant you can you can go to
brilliant org slash
tibbie's and sign up for free and the
first 200 people that follow that link
can get 20% off a premium and your
subscription so thanks to brilliant for
supporting this series and thank you
guys for watching all the way to
the end I've had a lot of fun here and
learnt a few things of my own so I think
I'm planning to do some more in this
sort of style but not on quantum
mechanics I'm open to suggestions I was
thinking maybe doing a bit of an intro
to special relativity like some more
computer science stuff with neural
networks or even a computational biology
which is I guess the area that's closest
to what I'm working in alright so thanks
for watching and I'll see you guys in
[Music]